is a man not entitled to take a break
from uploading videos on the YouTubes
hmm
hello everyone
[Laughter]
what a weird way to intro a video all
right uh so a lot of a lot of you guys
are kind of been asking like where's Rob
why isn't Rob making videos here's the
thing I had to take a step back from
Geek culture explain because with phase
four what I found is that with so little
content that actually mattered coming
out uh it was really difficult to
actually be motivated to make videos on
the channel right literally I found
myself hunting for things and basically
trying to craft theories out of nothing
you know like hey guys uh the M M's in
that bowl in the trailer for Ant-Man and
watch Quantum Mania are read obviously
Iron Man's coming back you know like it
was that kind of a thing and and because
of that it was just like like it just it
felt kind of Soul crushing right and
that along with running Comics explain
and then all the stuff that we're doing
on the back end was all just burning me
out so I just took a step back and I was
like okay like what do I actually want
to do here and my staff recognized that
right credit where credit's due you know
that's important and I cannot ignore
that so what I'm gonna do here and for
those of you guys who come from Comics
explained you guys remember over on that
channel we did two essay Style all
videos right one was on why people like
Batman more than Superman and the other
one came out around the time of Avengers
end game and it answered the question
should they recast Iron Man and I loved
doing those videos like they were really
really cool so we're gonna do those here
in fact here in a couple hours on this
channel I'm gonna upload a video
basically talking about how the Marvel
Cinematic Universe screwed up with phase
four but what I'm also going to do is
because I'm not Reddit and I'm not
Twitter I don't just complain about
problems I want to offer a solution to
that problem and so in that video what
I'm actually going to do is I'm going to
pitch my idea for what they should have
done with phase four and what they could
actually do going forward if you guys
were interested in that make sure you
guys stay tuned that video will be out
here in a couple hours that being said
guys this is what things are going to
look like for the future I get not
everybody's going to be on board with
that honestly I don't really care I'm
more concerned about keeping my mental
health sane as opposed to appealing to
the masses and you know burning myself
out in the pursuit of creating content
that everybody wants to see so this is
really more just kind of me doing my own
thing and uploading at my own Leisure
and and creating content at my own
Leisure and calling it a day so with
that being said guys uh we're gonna
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching I will see you guys here in
a few hours when that video gets
released peace